the following table of values represents
points x comma y on the graph of a
linear function determine the
y-intercept of this graph so just as a
reminder of what the y-intercept even is
if you imagine a linear function or a
line if we're graphing it
if we imagine a line so let's say that
is our line right over there this is our
y-axis this is our x-axis the
y-intercept is where we intersect the
y-axis now what do we know about the
y-intercept well at the y-intercept
x is going to be equal to 0. so this is
the point 0 comma
something and so when people are talking
about what is your y-intercept they're
usually saying well what is the what is
the y-coordinate when x equals 0. so
we're really trying to figure out what
is the y-coordinate when x equals 0. so
we know the x-coordinate when y is equal
to 0. so this is actually the
x-intercept so this point right over
here is the point two comma zero so when
people say x-intercept that's the that's
the x-coordinate when y equals zero well
they already they gave us the
x-intercept so that right over there is
the x
the x-intercept but what's the
y-intercept what is the y-value when x
equals 0.
let's see they give us what happens to y
when x is negative 2 when it's 1 when
it's 2 when it's 4 so maybe we can
backtrack from one of these to get back
to what happens when x is equal to zero
so let me rewrite let me rewrite this
table so i can give ourselves a little
bit more breathing room
so let's say we have x and we have y
x and y
and they already tell us that when x is
negative two x is negative two y is
eight and i actually wanna think about
what happens when x is negative one when
x is zero then they tell us when x is
one
y is two when x is two y 0 this right
over here is the x intercept when x is 4
y is negative 4. so they skip 2 right
over here y is negative 4. so let's just
see how y changes with respect to
changes in x
so when we go here when x changes by one
so when x changes by one
y
goes down
by two and it's a line so it's going to
have a constant rate of change of y with
respect to x so similarly when x
increases by one
y is going to decrease by two so y is
going to be six here when x increases by
one again y is going to decrease by 2.
so we're going to get to 4 and we see it
works because if we increase by 1 again
then it is indeed the case that y
decreased by 2. and you see here when we
increase x by 2
then y decreases at twice the rate
because now we didn't just increase by
one we increased by two so now y is
going to decrease by four and what's
constant here is your change in y
over your change in x when x
d when x increases by one y decreases by
two when x d increases by two y
decreases by four either way either
either way you think about it your
change in y for unit change in x is
going to be equal to negative 2. but
anyway we actually answered the question
before without even realizing it when we
filled in all of these values what is
the y value when x equals 0 well the y
value is 4. so the y-intercept here is
4. we didn't really graph this to scale
it would actually look a little bit more
like this if we were to try to graph it
properly
so
this right over here is 4
this right over here is 2
and our line looks something like this
our line
will look
something like
something
like that